now our usual studio audience hey
they're not here
uh they're watching at home so we're
going to hear their stories remotely
but we need someone to sit in the chair
and and take the punishment
so are you there jason manford hello see
now the pyjamas have come into their own
yes
i was also just thinking because me and
carly have sat in the same chair does
that mean
we're in each other's bubble now can i
just tell you
the chair was swapped out oh
one of you is disease-ridden oh fair
enough
i didn't wonder how i was going to
explain that to my wife
i'm gonna bring kylie home she's in our
six now
i'm in a bubble now okay so i don't know
quite how this will work jason we're
going to hear some stories i don't want
to get flipped so i want every one of
them to be an absolute
beauty have you seen the show yeah it's
unlikely
okay who's up first hello hello
hello hello what's your name sir uh
paul from uh gizmo near middlesbrough
okay are you outside
no i'm inside i'm in the room okay
is that a hedge behind you it's not the
dog it's the cushion
oh it's going okay oh it's a lovely
lovely is he filming this on a potato
it does look like we're doing this in
1968
we've we've managed to send someone to
the moon
i definitely saw clearer pictures of tim
peake than i'm seeing
before can i say hello to kylie of
course you can
hi hi kylie nice to see you
he might be handsome we don't know
yeah his face is made up of eight
squares
he's like self-pixelating i guess this
is a really
shocking story okay paul this is jason
jason you are you're
jason want you to tell a good story so
off you go all right jason
basically during lockdown hair got a bit
long got a bit messy
um no hairdresser's open so i thought
i'd have a go myself
got my hair got some shavers
got ready never made it too long
obviously going a bit thin on top
it did my hair no problem at all i
couldn't get around the back to cut my
hair
yes give the clippers to my wife took
the guard off give it to my wife
she went up the back of my head without
even talking to me
and that's it
[Applause]
[Applause]
good evening graham good evening
everybody what's your name sir
i'm annasley annesley and where are you
i'm in pinner in middlesex
what do you do in in pinner i'm a
political communications consultant well
now
who knew i know tempting no let's wait
let's wait let's see if uh daniel sloss
is ready in the chair
there he is look at him oh he's keen
he's keen
okay so you are going to tell a story
that will prevent
daniel sloss from being tipped in the
chair off you go sir
so um during the first lockdown i was um
tearing my hair out trying to find a
cleaner because nobody was available
yeah i mean was the expression tone deaf
invented for this
sorry daniel but i'm sure you'll agree
100
i was almost certain it was just me
throwing myself back there
in disgust hello my name is donna
looney why how are you tim peake from
space
had a better look had a better
connection
absolutely absolutely
where where are you i'm actually in west
meeting islands
okay off you go with your story okay
when i was younger
i was about 25 i was staying with
friends of mine and i grabbed a jumper
put it on my head and actually it got
stuck on my head i pulled down the zip
and the zip got up to my eyelid
but it wasn't even my jumper that's my
story
i'm so sorry victor we couldn't have
[Applause]
known
oh her jumper got stuck on her head it
wasn't even her jumper though
it wasn't even that that was the quarter
that was the topper
and i've got an idea for my next book
now
hello what's your name my name is judith
scott
lovely are you very far away judith
scott
i'm in brisbane australia today well
today
you know what i think i'll just let you
talk every day yeah i'll just i'll just
let you tell your story because the
chatty thing seems quite difficult
let's just tell your story okay well i
was on holiday as a newlywed
with my husband in canada and we were
staying with our in-laws
after a day out we went to an ice cream
shop
to get some ice creams i went to the lou
when i came out i saw that my husband
was bent over
looking at some ice cream pizzas he had
shorts on and
i had got into the habit of whenever
he's got shorts on i would run my hand
up his inside short leg and grab
and tug whatever i could find so i crept
over and ran my fingers
up his legs and pulled some pubic hair
out
out a normality roar came out of the
owner
as i realized it was my father-in-law's
leg not my husband he turned around
holding his brain good story
well big mouth and absolutely shocked i
think i think
you can walk you can walk that was a
good story yes
yeah thank you very good who are you my
name is melissa
field melissa from field
mansfield mansfield i see okay lovely
what do you do there i'm an
administrator an administrator
we found an administrator everybody yes
yeah okay
off you go with your story so we were
driving for a family down
and we come across an accident
unfortunately
and we got out this poor guy jack was on
the floor
pretty beaten up and as we get to him i
noticed his phone's ringing
girl's name anna's on the phone and he's
like don't worry
it's just my partner i'll give her a
call back later
paramedics turn up about 10 minutes
later
this lady turns up hysterical crying
shouting his name
comes over and i i click this must be
the partner
so i say oh hi are you anna she looks at
me confused
a little bit angry she's like no i'm sad
oh this is frozen
oh thank god oh my god oh my god oh what
happens next what happens next
turns out she'd suspected he'd been
cheating for a while
and i just confirmed it while the poor
guy had been picked up by paramedics
you can walk if there's room to walk
[Applause]
oh she's walking there hi what's your
name
sophie sophie and where are you sophie
lincoln
okay and what are you doing lincoln i'm
a probation service officer
oh no messing okay off you go with the
story
okay so a couple of years ago me and my
childhood best friend hannah went to
venice
for a europe city break and we are known
for being quite gormless
and dopey so we picked up this random
map for like a euro that we just like
found off
one of the side streets and thought
we'll follow it so it didn't have any
english it just had like loads of red
circles over it
and so we thought we'll go to the red
circle first one so off we walked down
the canals and the streets and things
like that and
got to this building didn't really look
great not many people around but
took some pictures and there was a
public toilet there so we thought great
well might as well go while we're here
i'm sorry hello
hello hi hi what's your name my name is
marianne
and where are you i'm in portugal
okay in portugal okay and what do you do
in portugal
uh i have an airbnb normally but at the
moment it's not really happening because
of the kovitz situation so i do some
translation on the
internet okay great and then i watch the
graham norton show every evening to
cheer me up
oh bless you well now thank you sorry i
just said
gareth so i think the tip is if you hold
on to the arms of the chair
all right okay okay i've never had to
coach anyone before but but
if you hold on you're in a safer
situation okay
okay okay
this is properly exciting uh okay off we
go with your story so
uh i lived in england when i was younger
i moved to england when i was 20 years
old
and after i've been there for a year or
so i decided that it was time for me to
check in with the hospital with a
gynecologist for this kind of
an annual checkup of the female bits and
it was an autumnal stormy
rainy day and i come in a bit nervous i
get in the chair with my legs up in the
stirrups feeling
uncomfortable and nervous and the doctor
walks in
and he says it's pouring out
and my face
i could not call that expressing him and
then together
you can walk you could walk well done
gareth's delighted hello
what's your name trish and where are you
trish
i'm in county mead in ireland okay trish
off you go with this story
okay so when i was 11 just two weeks
before my confirmation
i was having a race with a boy in my
school
i was desperate to beat him i was
running so fast
i ran into a wall literally bounced off
the wall
gave myself concussion and ended up in
hospital
with two broken wrists my mom said she
was absolutely mortified because the
doctor thought i'd been in a serious car
crash
and she had to say no she ran into a
wall
so my confirmation day we'd been
rehearsing for
days because the bishop was going to be
there it's a really important deal
i walked up the aisle my arms in plaster
of paris
very very nervous i knelt in front of
the bishop
but because my hands were in plaster i
couldn't steady myself and
i lost my balance completely and i went
headfirst into the bishop's crotch
hi what's your name francesca
francesca and where are you francesca
i'm
in north finchley in london lovely i
don't like the colour of your curtains
[Laughter]
i'm an actor and i also work in a local
pub okay so nothing
um unemployed
i've been there it gets better thank you
please put me on bridget and i'd love to
be on it yeah yeah yeah
all right off you go with your story and
remember you're trying to keep alan in
that chair okay
good luck everyone off you go okay so a
few years ago i was working in sheffield
in a theatre
and we have this barn restaurant where
the audience and cast
would come before and after a show one
night this famous person had been to see
the show
and came into the bar afterwards where i
served them
um and i was making their drinks i think
it was like two gin and tonics
and as i was making their drinks these
two cast members came over and started
asking for their photos and that kind of
thing
so i put the drinks on the bar they turn
around pick up their drinks
and then walk over to their table
without paying now you're probably
wondering who this famous person is
it was graham norton
[Applause]
i knew it was gonna be me i
never pay for drinks
how dare she ask me for money hello
oh god happy new year that is impressive
[Applause]
i really i'm sorry
that's the future hi what's your name hi
graham
hi my name is megan megan and where are
you megan
i'm from south africa okay is that where
you are
that's where i'm i am and where i'm from
i am south african
okay that's the whole thing there's no
there's nothing else to discuss here
she is south african she's in south
africa
and uh didn't get a lot of paintings for
christmas
okay off you go with your story megan
right so firstly i want to say this is
the best new year's eve and birthday
present ever
because the 31st is my birthday so thank
you for happy birthday
thank you this story better be good
otherwise i'm getting flipped
i'm going to do my best so the 31st of
december is my birthday
and a couple years back i was with my
italian boyfriend at the time
and i spent the entire day with him and
he didn't say a single word about my
birthday
i didn't say anything thinking maybe
he's got a surprise lined up
and did he have a surprise so we go to
this new year's eve party
and as the night goes on i'm getting
progressively more upset because it's
starting to dawn on me
that he's forgotten my birthday so the
countdown comes
five four three two one happy new year
he turns to me bella happy birthday
i'm so happy i'm number one to wish you
i looked at him and i said you were the
last to wish
got into the me heated argument where he
tried to convince me that i was wrong
i had to end the argument by fetching my
passport
to prove to him this is my birthday
you can walk you can walk
happy birthday
you